This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There's so much in our popular culture about the power of positive thinking. We're often told to follow our hearts, to dream big. You can have, do, or be anything you want. Whatever belief you hold in your subconscious mind will become your reality, bottom line. Value yourself and believe in yourself. Because believing that the dots will connect down the road will give you the confidence to follow your heart even when it leads you off the
这里是Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们的流行文化中充斥着关于积极思考力量的观点。我们经常被告知要听从内心，要敢于梦想。你可以拥有、去做或成为你想成为的任何东西。归根结底，你潜意识里的任何信念都会变成你的现实。相信并珍视你自己。因为坚信未来的点点滴滴终将连成一线，会给你信心去追随内心，哪怕它带你走上
well-worn path. But now, research a Gabrielle Eddie and says, maybe we should all dream a little smaller. Positive fantasies and daydreams as pleasurable they are, they have a problem when it comes to fulfilling our wishes and attaining our gold. Gabrielle is a professor at New York University, an author of the book, Rethinking Positive Thinking, Inside the New Science of Motivation. She's from Germany, and she said growing up, no one told her to shoot for the stars. I was raised in Europe, and the idea of big dreams, big hopes was if adult more implicit than explicit.
人迹罕至的路。但加布里埃尔·厄廷根（Gabriele Oettingen）的研究表明，也许我们都应该把梦想做小一点。积极的幻想和白日梦虽然令人愉悦，但在实现我们的愿望和达成目标时却存在问题。加布里埃尔是纽约大学的教授，也是《重新思考积极思考：动机新科学内幕》（Rethinking Positive Thinking, Inside the New Science of Motivation）一书的作者。她来自德国，她说在成长过程中，没有人告诉她要志存高远。我在欧洲长大，大梦想、大希望这种理念，对成年人来说更多是含蓄的而非明确的。
When she came to the United States, though, Gabrielle noticed a real cultural difference. Well, when I came to the America, it was wonderful because people always said, yes, do it. Yes, that's possible. Yeah. Okay, this is a good idea. Why don't you do it? Whereas back in Europe, people were more cautious and said, you know, are you sure you want to do this?
不过，当她来到美国时，加布里埃尔注意到了一种真正的文化差异。嗯，当我来到美国时，这太棒了，因为人们总是说，去吧，干吧。是的，那是可能的。是的，好吧，这是一个好主意。你为什么不去做呢？而在欧洲，人们则更加谨慎，并会说，你知道，你确定你想这么做吗？
Are you sure this is possible? So I was really happy to come to America because people were just sort of encouraging whatever idea you had. I was really happy to come to America because people were just sort of encouraging whatever idea you had. So yes, positive thinking, indulging in fantasies about the future. It does feel good. But when Gabrielle Hattie and Big Yandt research this topic, she found something interesting. Well, these positive fantasies, they seduce us to feel already accomplished and they take our energy away.
你确定这可能吗？所以我非常高兴来到美国，因为人们只是在某种程度上鼓励你拥有的任何想法。我非常高兴来到美国，因为人们只是在某种程度上鼓励你拥有的任何想法。所以，是的，积极思考，沉浸于对未来的幻想中。这确实感觉很好。但是，当加布里埃尔·厄廷根和研究这个课题时，她发现了一些有趣的事情。嗯，这些积极的幻想诱使我们觉得自己已经成功了，它们带走了我们的能量。
So we found that, for example, the more positively women enrolled in a weight reduction program, the fewer pounds they lost, three months later, one year later, two years later, or the more positively university graduates fantasized about an easy transition into work life, the fewer dollars they earn two years later, the fewer drop-overs they have gotten, and also the fewer drop-applications they had sent out, or take students. The more positively they fantasized about getting a good grade in their exam, the less well they did. Or the more positively they fantasized about getting a good grade in their exam, the less well they did. Or the more positively they fantasized about getting together with a crushy, the less likely they were to actually get in a romantic relationship.
所以我们发现，例如，参加减肥计划的女性表现得越积极，她们减掉的体重就越少——三个月后、一年后、两年后；或者大学毕业生对顺利过渡到职场幻想得越积极，他们两年后赚到的钱就越少，他们得到的职位就越少，他们投递的求职申请也越少；或者以学生为例。他们对在考试中取得好成绩幻想得越积极，他们考得就越糟。或者他们对在考试中取得好成绩幻想得越积极，他们考得就越糟。或者他们对和暗恋对象在一起幻想得越积极，他们实际发展成恋爱关系的几率就越小。
Or take the health domain. Same thing, the more positively hip replacement surgery patients fantasized about an easy recovery, the less well could they move their joint, the fewer steps they could take, and the less well they recovered from the surgery. So when you look at each of these cases, I'm wondering if you could tell me what you mean by a positive fantasy. So let's take the student, for example, who is hoping to go out on a date with someone that he or she likes. Do you sort of imagining for example going out on the date, things going really well? There's other person really liking you as much as you like them? Yeah, that's a good question actually. It's not so easy to measure these fantasies.
或者以健康领域为例。同样的事情，髋关节置换手术患者对顺利康复幻想得越积极，他们关节的活动度就越差，能走的步数就越少，手术后的恢复效果也就越差。因此，当你审视每一个这样的案例时，我想知道你所说的积极幻想究竟是什么意思。让我们以一个学生为例，他希望和自己喜欢的人约会。你是否在想象，比如去约会，事情进展得非常顺利？另一个人也像你喜欢他/她那样喜欢你？是的，这确实是个好问题。要衡量这些幻想其实并不容易。
So what we did is we gave participants a short story. So for example in the case of the people who had a crush on someone else, a short story describing how they meet this person and they then needed to end that story and that story could either end positively or they could end not so positively. So then participants fantasized and wrote down their fantasies about the ending of the story. And the more positively, these people had been fantasizing about getting together with their crushy,
所以我们做的是给参与者一个小故事。例如，对于那些对某人有好感的人，小故事描述了他们是如何遇到这个人的，然后他们需要给这个故事一个结尾，这个结尾可以以积极的方式结束，也可以以不太积极的方式结束。于是，参与者开始幻想并写下他们对故事结局的幻想。这些人在幻想和暗恋对象在一起时表现得越积极，
then less likely it was that they actually got together with the person they were in love. So, the idea really is, the more idealized, the more positively people fantasize, the less well they do because they don't put in the effort needed to actually reach the goals and fulfill the wishes. Now is it the case that people recovering from example hip replacement surgery, when they have positive fantasies of walking, at one level you would have to say this is deeply, deeply understandable.
那么他们真正和自己爱的人在一起的可能性就越小。因此，核心观点其实是：越是理想化、越是充满积极的幻想，人们的实际表现就越差，因为他们没有付出实现愿望和达成目标所需的努力。那么，对于那些例如从髋关节置换手术中恢复的人来说，当他们对行走抱有积极的幻想时，在某种程度上你不得不说这是深深的、可以理解的。
You know, you feel like you can't do the things that you're used to doing. You want to get back on your feet and you want to dream of the day when you would be able to walk or climb stairs or run without pain. Are you saying that that's a bad thing? No, I'm not saying it's a bad thing. Actually, we have very nice data showing that these positive fantasies, they actually come out of a person's needs and you are completely right. A person who has a surgery and who used to be able to walk feels a need to walk like before and there the positive fantasies come from and I don't say these are bad things at all because they are the beginning of action but they are only the beginning, they give action the direction but they
你知道，你会觉得自己无法做那些习惯做的事情。你想要重新站起来，你想要梦想着有一天能够毫无痛苦地行走、爬楼梯或跑步。你是说这是一件坏事吗？不，我并不是说这是一件坏事。事实上，我们有非常好的数据表明，这些积极的幻想实际上源于一个人的需求，你是完全正确的。一个做过手术、以前能够行走的人感到了像以前一样行走的需要，积极幻想正是来源于此，而且我绝不认为这些是坏事，因为它们是行动的开始，但它们只是开始，它们为行动提供了方向，但它们
don't give action the necessary energy. In fact, when we induce participants to positively fantasize, to ideally depict them, positive future, then we find that the blood pressure goes down and then we find that the feelings of energization go down and we find that people feel already accomplished. So they relax, they relax because mentally they are already there. There is something terribly sad about this, which is that the person imagines the happy future, perhaps because they are not very happy at the present, but by so doing, they in some ways deprive themselves of the energy and motivation they need to make their futures actually better and thereby make their futures worse.
并没有为行动提供必要的能量。事实上，当我们引导参与者进行积极幻想，理想化地描绘积极的未来时，我们发现他们的血压下降了，我们发现他们的活力感下降了，我们发现人们觉得自己已经成功了。所以他们放松了，他们放松是因为他们在精神上已经到达了那里。这里面有一种极其悲哀的事情，那就是一个人想象着幸福的未来，也许是因为他们对现状不是很满意，但通过这样做，他们在某种程度上剥夺了让未来真正变好所需的能量和动机，从而让他们的未来变得更糟。
It feels like a vicious cycle. Well, it is not so sad if you consider that if you actually complement these positive fantasies with considerations of what stands in the way, what is it in you that stands in the way that you actually fulfill your wishes and attain your goals, that then you actually get the energy and if these goals are attainable, then you really go for it. When we come back, we'll talk about the next steps to make that day dream a reality. You think about the next four weeks. Now in the next four weeks, what is your most important wish? Stay with us.
这感觉就像一个恶性循环。嗯，如果你考虑到，如果你将这些积极的幻想与对阻碍因素的思考结合起来——思考你身上有什么东西阻碍了你实现愿望和达成目标——那么你就会真正获得能量，如果这些目标是可达到的，那么你就会全力以赴。我们回来后，将讨论把白日梦变成现实的下一步。想想接下来的四周。现在，在接下来的四周里，你最重要的愿望是什么？请继续收听。
Gabrielle Eddie and his found that positive thinking, while fun, may not really be the answer to achieving your goals. But she does say that noticing your dreams and thinking about what you really want can be the first step to making them a reality. You've done a lot of work looking not just at the potential downside of these positive fantasies, but also how we can use these positive fantasies in a very productive way, and you call it mental contrasting. What is mental contrasting?
加布里埃尔·厄廷根发现，积极思考虽然有趣，但可能并不是实现目标的真正答案。但她确实说过，注意到你的梦想并思考你真正想要什么，可以成为将其变为现实的第一步。你做了很多研究，不仅关注这些积极幻想的潜在负面影响，还关注我们如何以非常富有成效的方式利用这些积极幻想，你称之为心理对比。什么是心理对比？
Mental contrasting is a strategy to fulfill your wishes and attain your goals. So you first identify a wish. A wish that is very dear to you. So for example, you think about the next four weeks. Now in the next four weeks, what is your most important wish? Can be a professional wish, can be an interpersonal wish, can be health wish. This wish should be a wish that is a little challenging for you, but that you actually can fulfill yourself. that you actually can fulfill yourself. Now, identify that wish and keep it in front of your mind.
心理对比是一种实现愿望和达成目标的策略。所以你首先要确定一个愿望。一个对你非常珍贵的愿望。比如，你想想接下来的四周。现在，在接下来的四周里，你最重要的愿望是什么？可以是一个职业愿望，可以是一个人际交往愿望，可以是一个健康愿望。这个愿望应该对你来说有点挑战性，但你实际上可以靠自己去实现。你实际上可以靠自己去实现。现在，找出这个愿望，并把它铭记在心。
What you do then is you think about what would be the best thing, the best outcome if I fulfilled myself that wish. And once you identify that and put it in front of your mind, then you imagine that best thing. If you recognize now, imagining that best thing is like positively fantasizing. These are the positive date rims we are just talking about. But then instead of carrying on with these positive fantasies, you know which gears and you say to yourself.
你接下来要做的是，思考如果我实现了这个愿望，最好的事情、最好的结果会是什么。一旦你确定了这一点并把它放在脑海中，你就会想象那件最好的事情。如果你现在意识到，想象那件最好的事情就像积极的幻想。这就是我们刚才谈论的积极白日梦。但随后，与其继续这些积极的幻想，你知道要转换档位，并对自己说：
Actually, what stops me from fulfilling my wish and experiencing that outcome? What is it in me that stands in the way? What is my inner obstacle? What is it in me? And then once you identified your inner obstacle and you need a little bit of humor and a little bit of honesty to yourself. Sometimes it's not so pleasant. You don't need to tell anybody, but you can identify that obstacle and then you say to yourself,
实际上，是什么阻止了我的愿望实现并体验到那个结果？我内心有什么东西阻碍着我？我的内在障碍是什么？我身上有什么？一旦你找到了内在障碍，你需要带一点幽默感，对自己有一点诚实。有时这并不是那么令人愉快。你不必告诉任何人，但你可以找出那个障碍，然后对自己说：
if that obstacle occurs, then I will show a behavior or think of a thought to overcome that obstacle. So if obstacle, then I will behavior to overcome obstacle. And that's what in the science language is called mental contrasting, with implementation intentions. To forget this complicated name, it's called in the science literature, also MCII. But we renamed it now, and it's called now whoop for wish. First we started with a wish. Outcome we then went on to identify that outcome and imagine that outcome. Obstacle remember the obstacle, identify the obstacle, imagine the obstacle and then the plan. The if
如果那个障碍出现，那么我将表现出某种行为或想到某种想法来克服这个障碍。所以，如果出现障碍，我就会采取行动克服障碍。在科学语言中，这被称为带有实施意图的心理对比。忘掉这个复杂的名称吧，它在科学文献中也被称为MCII。但我们现在给它重新命名了，现在它被称为WHOOP，取自Wish（愿望）。首先我们从愿望开始。Outcome（结果），然后我们继续确定该结果并想象该结果。Obstacle（障碍），记住障碍，识别障碍，想象障碍，然后是Plan（计划）。如果
obstacle then I will overcome plan. And that's called whoop. I asked Gabrielle how she would apply her strategy to someone who has a crush on another person, but instead of doing something about it, it's just sitting around daydreaming about a blissful honeymoon. What would that person do if they wanted to use mental contrasting or whoop? So let's say you have a young person who's interested in another person. And so the wish would be, you know, I want to go with him or with her on a date and want to explore a little bit deeper what that person is all about. So that would be the wish. The best outcome might be something
出现障碍，那么我将采取克服计划。这就叫做WHOOP。我问加布里埃尔，她会如何将她的策略应用到这样一个人身上：他暗恋另一个人，但不是采取行动，而是坐着白日梦，幻想幸福的蜜月。如果这个人想使用心理对比或WHOOP，他会怎么做？所以，假设你有一个对另一个人感兴趣的年轻人。所以愿望会是，你知道，我想和他或她去约会，并想更深入地了解那个人到底是怎样的人。这就是愿望。最好的结果可能是这样的：
like, you know, we would have a really good time and we would feel kind of in harmony. But then the person would change gears and say, what is it in me that stands in the way that I actually fulfill my wish, that I ask this person out for a date and experience the harmony? So what is it in me that stands in the way? And then the person might discover, hmm, I might feel too shy or I'm a little bit anxious, reluctant to get a rejection. And then the person can elaborate on their China's to be rejected, that fear of rejection can really elaborate on it, kind of understand,
比如，我们会玩得很开心，我们会感到一种和谐。但随后这个人会转换档位，说：我内心有什么东西阻碍了我真正实现愿望，阻碍了我邀请这个人去约会并体验这种和谐？所以，我内心有什么东西阻碍着我？然后这个人可能会发现，嗯，我可能觉得太害羞了，或者我有点焦虑，不愿意接受拒绝。然后这个人可以详细阐述他们对被拒绝的羞怯，这种对拒绝的恐惧可以真正详细阐述，从而理解：
oh yeah, this fear, that's my obstacle. And after that, the person could think, what can I do to overcome this fear of rejection? So what can the person do? The person can sort of understand, well, if the person rejected me, then I'm there where I'm right now, because if I don't talk to that person, I will not meet the person anyway. So I can't really lose anything.
哦，是的，这种恐惧，这就是我的障碍。在这之后，这个人可以思考：我能做些什么来克服这种对拒绝的恐惧？所以这个人能做些什么呢？这个人可以这样理解：好吧，如果这个人拒绝了我，那么我还在我现在呆的地方，因为如果我不和这个人说话，我无论如何也见不到这个人。所以我其实没什么可失去的。
And then he or she could do the if-then plan. If I feel that fear of rejection, then I will tell myself, just go to that person and approach him or her because I can't lose anything. And then the person will non-consciously outside of awareness, approach that person by sort of overcoming one's fears of rejection. One of the things that I find so striking is that third step doesn't involve saying, what are the obstacles in my path?
然后他或她就可以制定“如果-那么”计划。如果我感到这种对拒绝的恐惧，那么我会告诉自己，直接去找那个人，向他或她走去，因为我没有什么可失去的。然后这个人就会在无意识中、在觉察之外，通过某种方式克服对拒绝的恐惧，走向那个人。让我觉得非常震撼的一点是，第三步并不涉及说：我道路上的障碍是什么？
But you ask, what are the obstacles in me that prevent me from achieving the score? That's correct, because the obstacles in me doesn't allow me to come up with all these excuses. So if I say, what are the obstacles in my path, I could say, well, this person is in a different building or whatever, or studies a different topic, or I don't have the time, or I'm just busy right now, and all these excuses, they fall away, if you ask, what is it in you that stands in the way?
而是你问：我体内有哪些障碍阻止我实现这个目标？没错，因为我体内的障碍不允许我想出所有这些借口。所以如果我说，我道路上的障碍是什么，我可以说，嗯，这个人不在同一栋楼里，或者学不同的专业，或者我没有时间，或者我现在正忙，如果问你内心有什么东西阻碍了你，所有这些借口都会烟消云散。
What is it really that stands in the way? Now you extract the information out of that negative feedback without getting hurt. So you don't take it personally, but you take the information and compost in this negative feedback and you use it to make the correct plans. Has metal contrasting changed anything that you do? Well, I'm using a wolf on a daily basis and we have devised next to the book we have devised an app which gives you the instructions of metal contrasting with implementation and intentions of whoop. So it leads you through the four steps, which outcome, obstacle, plan.
到底是什么在阻碍着你？现在，你从这些负面反馈中提取信息，而不会受到伤害。所以你不要把这当作针对个人，而是把这些负面反馈中的信息进行转化利用，并用它来制定正确的计划。心理对比改变了你的任何做法吗？嗯，我每天都在使用WHOOP，除了这本书，我们还开发了一个应用程序，它为你提供带有实施意图的心理对比（即WHOOP）的使用说明。它引导你走过四个步骤：愿望、结果、障碍、计划。
And interestingly enough, I thought I'm an expert on whoop, but I'm using the app every day actually. I'm using the app because it forces me to specify my wish, to specify my outcome, to imagine the outcome, to specify my inner obstacle, to imagine the inner obstacle, and to form a very specific if obstacle, then I will be able to overcome obstacle plan. So I do it every morning. Other people do it in the evening or you know doing lunch break or when they wait for the bus or in the subway. What you need though for doing a group, you need to have a quiet moment for yourself. You can be in the subway when everybody is talking but you need to be uninterrupted. You can be in some way when everybody is talking, but you need to be uninterrupted. You can't do your email, you can't talk to someone while you're doing a whoop. So you need to have a moment for yourself where you think, what is my wish?
有趣的是，我以为我是WHOOP专家，但我实际上每天都在使用这个App。我使用这个App是因为它迫使我明确我的愿望，明确我的结果，想象结果，明确我的内在障碍，想象内在障碍，并形成一个非常具体的“如果出现障碍，我将能够克服障碍”的计划。所以我每天早上都这样做。其他人则在晚上这样做，或者你知道的，在午休时，或者当他们等公交车时，或者在地铁里。不过，要做WHOOP，你需要有一段属于你自己的安静时光。当每个人都在说话时，你不能在地铁里，但你需要不被打扰。当每个人都在说话时，你不能在某种程度上这样做，但你需要不被打扰。在做WHOOP时，你不能处理电子邮件，你不能和别人说话。所以你需要有属于你自己的时刻去思考：我的愿望是什么？
What is my wish for today? Or you might think, what is my wish for the next four weeks? Or what do I want in life? What is it really that I want? So you can whoop, very big wishes, or you can whoop, trivial wishes. But what is important, it needs to be a wish which is dear to your heart. And the nice thing with whoop is that it also allows you to finally think about what do I really want.
我今天的愿望是什么？或者你可能会想，我接下来四周的愿望是什么？或者我在生活中想要什么？我真正想要的是什么？所以你可以对非常宏大的愿望进行WHOOP，或者你可以对琐碎的愿望进行WHOOP。但重要的是，它需要是一个你内心里珍视的愿望。WHOOP的好处在于，它还允许你最终思考：我到底想要什么？
Gabrielle Etienne is a professor of psychology at New York University. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Lucy Perkins, Parts Shah and Renee Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. This week's unsung hero is Jessica Goldstein, who is the director of events and strategic initiatives at NPR. Jessica helped with our live taping in Aspen a few weeks ago. She's someone who dots the eyes and crosses the tees and then goes back and double checks
加布里埃尔·厄廷根是纽约大学心理学教授。本期《Hidden Brain》由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）和马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）制作。我们的团队包括詹妮弗·施密特（Jennifer Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、露西·帕金斯（Lucy Perkins）、帕茨·沙阿（Parts Shah）和雷妮·克莱尔（Renee Clarre）。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。本周的无名英雄是杰西卡·戈德斯坦（Jessica Goldstein），她是NPR的活动和战略倡议总监。杰西卡几周前协助了我们在阿斯彭的现场录音。她是一个做事一丝不苟、反复核对一切的人
everything. Thanks Jessica. One last thing before we go, we're working on a story about male friendships. This new research that suggests that many men, especially over the age of 50, find themselves with fewer friends and intimate relationships than they had in their 20s and 30s. Loneliness and social isolation are powerful determinants
谢谢你，杰西卡。在我们离开之前还有最后一件事，我们正在做一个关于男性友谊的故事。这项新研究表明，许多男性，尤其是50岁以上的男性，发现自己拥有的朋友和亲密关系比他们在20多岁和30多岁时要少。孤独和社会隔离是决定
of health and wellbeing. If you're a man over the age of 50 who's willing to share with us a story about the effect that loneliness has on your life, please give us a call at 661-772-7246. That's 661-778-brain. You can also record a voice memo on your smartphone and email it to us at hiddenbrainatnpr.org. Again, that's hiddenbrain1wordatnpr.org. And thanks, I'm Shankar Vitantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
健康和福祉的强大因素。如果你是一位50岁以上的男性，愿意与我们分享孤独对你生活影响的故事，请致电661-772-7246联系我们。即661-778-brain。你也可以在智能手机上录制语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：hiddenbrain@npr.org。再次重复，邮箱是hiddenbrain（连在一起）@npr.org。谢谢，我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。